some of you may be wondering whether
you're actually in a relationship with a
psychopath or whether that you've you
might have fallen for a psychopath in
the past and if you are in a
relationship with a psychopath what you
can do about that now
Psychopaths do have certain
characteristics certain tells to use a
poker analogy that they display in
relationships they tend to play on our
pity a lot okay so they tend to excuse
their misdemeanors and bad behaviors
through something that would beyond
their control they couldn't help doing
it because you know something had
happened and you know there's always an
excuse for it and although Psychopaths
don't feel emotions like us they are
masters at pushing those emotional hot
buttons that elicit emotions in others
in us
sympathy being one of the major major
motivators okay a psychopath also tend
to be very narcissistic they tend to
think that the world centers around them
they're not really attuned to your
feelings they don't really care about
your feelings really ultimately the
world surrounds surrounds then
psychopaths are also very charming
they're very manipulative especially
when they're in a crowd especially when
they're in company but behind the scenes
when they're alone with you they can be
very very controlling sometimes but not
always aggressive but psychologically
controlling as well okay so if you're
worried about the fact if you're worried
that you're you know in a relationship
with a psychopath what can you do about
that what might be some certain things
do to look out for well first of all the
absolute first thing to do is to not go
on face value to not fall for the
smokescreen okay a number-one rule of
thumb is to don't judge a person on what
they say but judge a person on what they
do okay so that's the very first thing
look at the evidence of their behavior
and try to judge it objectively rather
than
objectively not an easy thing to do I
admit if you're in a relationship with
someone secondly if you suspect that
your partner is a psychopath why don't
you get a second opinion from one of
your friends why don't you confide in
your friends I think my partner is a
psychopath or I think these are the
certain characteristics give me an
honest opinion what do you really think
about my partner okay and a second
opinion
two heads are often better than one in
this kind of case thirdly
none a golden rule is don't cover for
them if they start getting into serious
trouble and they want you to somehow
front up for them or be an alibi or
somehow make excuses or whatever
whatever don't get tangled up into
covering up for them because as soon as
that starts happening it's called the
foot in the door technique a very very
common persuasive technique once you've
done something for someone you're more
likely to do other follow-up things for
them and before you know it you're in up
to your neck okay and the fourth thing I
would say is buy my book because all the
all the signs and all the tricks of the
trade are in there and forewarned is
definitely for armed when you're dealing
with Psychopaths
you